The two other points on this parabola are negative 1 and negative 5 and
positive 1 comma 5. Good thinking if you checked those 2. What's so different
now is that our graph is going to open downward since we have a negative value
in front of the x squared. To find our basic shape, we'll start at 0, 0, the
vertex. Next we'll move one unit left and five units down. This gives us our
first point of negative 1, negative 5. Remember, the a value will always tell
us how many units to move up or down when our parabola is in the form y equals.
And since our parabola is symmetric about the y-axis, we can also go one unit
to the right, and five units down. This gives us our other point of 1 comma
negative 5. One of the key takeaways from this exercise is that a parabola in
the form y equals will always open upward, or it will open downward. If the a
value is positive, like in these three, we know the parabola opens upward. But
if the a value is negative, like in these two graphs, we know the parabola will
open downward.